final press conference following the
March European Council without further
ado I first invite the President of the
European Council Donald Tusk
to take the role listen thank you a
problem
jean-claude in good afternoon today
leaders discussed how to best prepare
the EU for increasing global economic
competition this means strengthening the
European single market and industrial
base which is key for job creation we
also agreed on the needs of an open and
assertive trade policy in this context
the European Council called to resume
the discussion on the public procurement
instrument we wanted to reign for
European capacity to deal with
technology theft and cyber security
threats and we look forward to the
Commission's recommendation on the
security of 5g networks we also
discussed the priorities for next
month's summit with China our aim is to
focus on achieving a balanced relation
which ensures fair competition and equal
market access in this context we hope to
persuade China to include industrial
subsidies as a crucial element of the
WTO reform additionally leaders were
univocal in the determination to tackle
climate change with urgency and ambition
our ministers identify work on the EU s
climate strategy to implement the goals
set down by the Paris agreement we will
come back to this issue in June regard
brexit the European Council formalized
last night's decisions by the EU 27 and
the UK to delay the cleavage and allow
for an extension personally I am really
happy about this development as I said
yesterday it means that until the 12th
of April anything is possible
a deal a long extension if the UK decide
the to rethink its strategy or revoking
article 50 which is a prerogative of the
UK government the fate of brexit is in
the hands of our British friends we are
they you we are prepared for for the
worst but hope for the best if you know
hope dies last thank you thank you and
now president Juncker of the European
Commission
we must you please don't share them yes
thank you very much well president my
dear friends we didn't just talk about
the United Kingdom we talked about to
China as well it was much more easy to
talk about China than it was to talk
about the United Kingdom I have to say
not the China is asking to join the
European Union but it's because it's not
leaving the European Union our relations
with China are yes well after I put it
there good relations not excellent China
is a competitor a partner arrival and we
need to adjust to this a change in
international relations trade between
China and the EU is asymmetrical and
anything that's asymmetrical leads to
imbalances and we can't create something
stable on the basis of something that
continues to be imbalanced we don't have
the reciprocity that we need in our
trade relationship with China and
competition between China and the
European Union is not fair which is why
we want to conclude an agreement on
investments with a China
this is something that we've been
discussing for some time I believe this
week I was I discussed this with a
Ministry of Foreign Affairs in China and
I will be discussing this on Tuesday
morning next week president in Paris
president Matt Cole has invited
China they'll be Germany Angela Merkel
as well and I think that this will be a
way of preparing for the summit with a
China and reaching out to public opinion
Chinese markets are not sufficiently
open to European products Chinese
markets exclude us to a great extent
China is able to take part in public
procurement in Europe it would be good
if Europe could do the same in China and
this is not a minor thing
it's 2.4 billion that are accessible to
companies outside the European Union but
out of the the 8 billion
the European Union doesn't only has
access to 10 billion so there's a lot of
work to be done which means that there
was an initial proposal in 2012 and then
a proposal was made for international
procurement I talked about this with
heads of state and government at this
morning something else is very important
is a new framework for investment
screening this is a very important
instrument which will mean that Europe
has an economy that is open but at the
same time has the checks and balances in
place to ensure that the same checks and
balances to ensure that we are on a
level playing field between all of the
competitors on a market now this
screening mechanism is to enter into
force on the 1st of April I believe this
year and if we had had this mechanism in
place we could have covered 83% of
Chinese foreign direct investment in a
2018 so this is a major issue now I can
see that you're impressed but you won't
but I suppose that you won't be for long
I open the floor for questions I think
Christian what's the first ok sir
we mojo Casey Mendell HP is every palate
yes thank you earlier on you talked
about 5g security you said that you're
going to be meeting the Chinese fairly
soon do you think that Y way it should
be banned from the 5g and telecom
markets in Europe or do you not share
the same vision as the United States and
then another question could you talk
about thing just like that at the end of
a summit
yeah why did you take so little to
discuss an issue like this that's so
important to citizens dear friends this
information rumors I think it's a woman
say that we discuss this information
just at the end of the meeting no I
think there's a whole process but feeds
into our meetings and it takes months to
do the work to lead up to our summit and
because of that work we managed to reach
an agreement very quickly on the text on
this information
now as the said I met the Chinese
Minister recently and oddly enough he
didn't mention 5g and oddly enough I
didn't mention 5g because the Commission
is in the process of throwing up a
communication which will be submitted
for your perusal
in 15 days and thank you and the next
question goes to the gentleman here in
the first row in the middle thank you
[Music]
we've met mark Stone from Sky News and
you seemed and you still seem in fact
almost giddy at the result that you came
up with last night on brexit but
essentially you have simply kicked the
canned
on the road again given the pattern that
we see from Westminster are the chances
not just still just as high of being on
the eve of No Deal on the 11th of April
and a question a second question if I
may you've celebrated the 25th
anniversary of the European Economic
Area today do you expect you'll
celebrate the 26th birthday with the UK
present the road the Canon has in
perspective is a very photon yeah I
think we are not the best address for
this question you know it's we and we
will be also really determined to to
achieve the best possible possible deal
and but almost everything is now in the
hands of the British Parliament and Rita
mates government I think that you know
my position it's a more pro-british than
new I think it's the next question goes
through the lady on all right
thank you everybody scatters sorry to be
asking you a question about an issue
that was not directly on your agenda but
the world doesn't stop when they use
summits take place it's about the Golan
Heights and the US president Donald
Trump's declaration that he wants to
recognize the sovereignty of Israel over
the territory it looks like it's a
statement that would mark a sharp change
of policy from the US on this delicate
issue and in the middle of a political
campaign in Israel so where does the EU
standard does it change the EU's
position in any way thank you we didn't
discuss this today but because the youth
position is well known and and has not
changed this is why it wasn't a topic
for today's discussion I think that mrs.
Mogollon has issued a statement related
to this
gholem issue you can refer to that
that's great and then a very last
question I think David I had you
gentlemen here in the middle
thanks David Hearn with Politico I was
struck by your for both presidents by
your comparison to the discussions about
China and the discussions about the UK
both potential partners but also
potential rivals in the future and I
wonder if you could talk to us a little
bit is the EU tough enough to handle
these rivalries or put another way to
China respect investment screening or
naval ships in the South China Sea I
mentally not not able to do two to three
today equally the UK and in China you
know it's and for me the UK is still a
member of our family not arrival by the
way I didn't compare China to wit but
I'm more in your sense of humor
thank you this concludes the press
conference